DM Minister Hilinski DM is Vandal DME
sky dear mrs. Barrus ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the ftth conference
it's a pleasure to see you all here in
war so I have two things that I would
like to say right at the start first you
have had an incredibly busy year since
our last meeting at the ftth conference
in stock oh and second I'm increasingly
optimistic about the future of t th and
not only for that we see ftth needed we
ask for fiber all the way today
throughout Europe so what have you been
doing as the council since we met last
year well plenty I can tell you we've
been actively engaged with policymakers
on practical matters bringing our
expertise and experience to bear on
issues like how to reduce the cost of
rolling out FTTH infrastructure when and
where this can make a difference and
where it wants we've also been actively
engaged with policy development and on
the type of measures that policymakers
need to put in place to ensure the rapid
deployment of FTTH by commercial
operators we also worked very closely
with the finance community to look at
issues around funding issues around the
industry structure and the need to
create the right conditions to allow
investors to make the necessary
long-term investments in infrastructure
we continue to run our Investor Day
events throughout Europe which gives
service providers and FTTH project
managers the chance to meet and engage
with the investment community we have
also been talking with the new European
commissioners Commissioner Athena and
Vice President Dan zip and their teams
are already working on the next
regulatory framework and they are doing
so in a very open and constructive way
we hear a lot about net neutrality today
but one of the biggest challenges for us
as an organization is to ensure that we
have a proper understanding
of technological neutrality while we all
agree that market players are best
placed to fake technology choices in
well-functioning markets that view is
turned on it said the market are
characterized by market failure in
Europe the fixed access network market
is characterized by market failure in
every one of the 28 countries in the
European Union and that's why the fixed
access network market is regulated in
every one of those countries the problem
is that today you can make almost any
technology choice and it will be capable
of delivering the speed that
policymakers are looking for however if
you choose today and limit yourself what
will that help you with tomorrow
unfortunately when it comes to
technology choices policy makers say
it's none of the business and are
reluctant to get involved meanwhile the
dominant companies are free to choose
the technology that solves their
short-term problems but does not meet
the long-term aspiration of Europe
citizens to be clear the ftth Council
Europe is not asking policymakers to
specify the actual technology they would
like to see but we believe that they
should at a minimum specify the
performance characteristics of the
candidate technology in more detail
whether that is upload speeds service up
time or ability for the physical network
to be unbundled in other words can the
network be shared with rival operators
to encourage competition competition in
retail services the fact that
policymakers do not specify these
characteristics does not make sense in
the context of the European regulatory
framework to give Commissioner thing and
vice president answered credit they are
approaching at their task in a very open
and constructive way and they are
clearly seeking out the best way to
proceed for everyone in the industry
today let me say however I think it's
absolutely vital that we put consumers
at the heart of this discussion we know
that cuz
you miss would pay for high speed once
they understand what they can actually
do with those high speeds if we have
well informed consumers who are able to
choose from a range of suppliers we will
have a dynamic and responsive market and
that will benefit not just the
individual consumer but society in
general and even the broadband industry
itself our research has found the
service providers receive higher
revenues from FTTH customers than they
do from dsl customers forty-six percent
higher on average in fact this is not
just because high speeds can often
command higher prices but FTC
subscribers tend to buy additional
services from the service providers
continuously when people are given the
option to do more with their broadband
connection PC that they grab it with
both hands however unfortunately the
current wave of confusing and sometimes
misleading advertising from service
providers can undermine not just consume
a trust but also that transition from
low to high speed broadband networks
this misleading advertising may reduce
the customers willingness to pay for
better services which in turn would
reduce income that operators can earn
and therefore the amount they can spay
spend on new network investments the
issue of transparency in broadband
advertising is not simply one of user
rights although of course customers
should get what they pay for we believe
it's crucial for them and an issue that
could affect the development and the
take-up of advanced networks and
services which could have a much more
significant impact both on the service
providers ability to invest but also on
our general economy turning to the
subject of the digital divide I'm not
the only one speaking on that today we
know that customers and consumers in the
major towns and cities are likely to
receive the network and services they
want and need on
purely commercial basis however for
residents of less densely populated
areas the use of public funds to support
the widespread deployment of FTTH is
both needed and justified it is
justified because these networks have
the potential to deliver enormous social
and economic benefits to to the
communities into the countries that use
them many of the potential applications
of FTTH such as home working and home
based healthcare monitoring of elderly
have significant positive impacts
associated with them which spillover of
course into other areas of society in
the case of home working just as an
example it could reduce traffic
congestion on the roads allowing other
commuters to save time on their journeys
as well as helping the environment the
economics of better broadband are not in
doubt it is well established at higher
broadband penetration and economic
development go hand in hand but now
evidence is also emerging that faster
broadband speeds have even greater
impact a doubling of a country's
broadband speed produces an increase in
GDP of 0.3% on average and further
doublings in speed produced further
increases according to a study conducted
by ericsson authored a little and the
Chalmers University of Technology in
Gothenburg in Germany alone the columbia
institute of tell information calculated
a significant impact in investments in
ultra-fast broadband networks bringing
FTTH to half the country would deliver
the equivalent of 0.6% annual growth in
the gdp over a ten-year period and
create more than half a million
construction jobs of course Germany is
not the only country that could benefit
from FTTH investments in the context of
new the new commissions whose mandate is
to overcome the stagnation in the
European economy such investments would
create literally hundreds of thousands
of construction and telecom jobs in the
short term while boosting business
productivity and growth especially in
knowledge-based industries in the medium
term president yanka has already
identified the need for Europe to fill
in an infrastructure gap be fully agree
and note that such initiatives drive
both the short and long term benefits
that Europe actually needs right now now
at the start of this speech I note that
i'm increasingly optimistic about the
future and from many good reasons the
main reason is that i see a new
enthusiasm for rolling out the ftth all
across Europe this is driven largely by
private commercial interest but the
public sector today is also making a
very important contribution taking fiber
to places where the private interest
alone wouldn't reach I see a new
recognition in the European Commission
of the need for long-term investments in
infrastructure and I see the recognition
echoed by the Member States when I look
at countries like Ireland where we see
Vodafone investing with the energy
utility to reach a quarter of all
households we see the incumbent reacting
and we see the Irish government taking
the initiative to drive fiber even
further and deeper to cover the final
third of the population and I also look
to Poland of course and I see the
proposal to build on the investments
made under the previous round of
European structural fonts and use them
to drive fiber further into access
networks today and over the coming years
I see the strategy they have worked on
and developed over the last few years
and it's starting to have a big impact
today I see the European Commission's
investment package which seeks to
simulate strategic investment of 315
billion euros and I see the potential
projects identified by the joint task
force of the Commission and the eib
include many network infrastructure and
especially fiber investing
however if public sector finance
assistance or support is to be given to
a broadband network surely that network
must be designed to be serviced able for
the next 10 20 or 30 years putting
public funds into short-term solutions
is a waste of taxpayers money some
countries in Europe have already made
that mistake and are wondering what to
do now now that they see the more
forward-thinking neighbors up for an
approach that delivers better
performance and is ready for the future
we still have a lot of work to do to
bring FTTH to the whole of Europe the
battle is not yet won but I have a
strong feeling and discerns that we are
on the right track we at the vibe to
them cancel Europe will continue to
insist that ftth is essential to
Europe's future it's essential for the
economic economic development of
countries in Europe it's essential for
social development in Europe it's
important today and it will only become
more important over the next decade and
beyond so by that I would like to
welcome you to the ftth conference and
welcome to the future thank
you